Before we go,
would it be possible to play a round
of the Final Five with you?
Yes.
Okay, okay, good.
Yeah.
All right, well, it's time with Sabrina Carpenter
for the Final Five!
(audience cheers)
All right, best song to clean to?
Nine to five, Dolly Parton.
Yes!
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, who would you love to do a collab with?
Oh my goodness,
maybe Bruno Mars.
I love Bruno Mars.
Have you ever seen him on Saturday Night Live
and he does the Pandora Station
where he has to be like 15 different musical acts?
Yeah.
It's one of the great things.
That's crazy, he's so good.
Okay, if you were not a singer, you would be?
Oh, a casting director, maybe?
I think that'd be so fun.
I know, hear me out though,
watching everyone's interpretation of the same thing
but they're completely different.
I've just always wanted to know what that's like.
Why is your jaw still there?
I love that answer.
(Sabrina laughs)
Okay, good!
It's so unexpected.
And it's funny, Joseph Gordon Levitt was on this show
and a casting director changed his life
because he was kind to him.
You know, you put yourself out there.
It's very uncomfortable.
Yeah.
(audience claps)
Okay, an instrument you would love to play?
An instrument I would love to play, violin.
It's just so cool or saxophone, you know?
Oh, I could see you doing any
one of those wind instruments.
We'll see.
If I do it, I'll tag you.
Just be like, "I did it."
Please do.
Yeah.
Okay, I really wanna make sure to bring up Fast Times
which we've been playing in the studio all day.
Thank you.
I've been watching the video obsessively,
which you are so confident and beautiful,
and there's a very like action figure,
cool, rock star.
You have a tremendous amount
of sensual confidence in it.
That means a lot from you.
I will say, one of our main references for that video
was I'm sure you could maybe sense
Charlie's Angels slightly.
Really?
Yeah, it was absolutely.
I was just like, "I want that."
I was like, "That looks great."
We would never even come close,
but I think kind of living in that world
of Kill Bill and Tarantino,
I think there was...
That's a Tarantino poster right there.
Totally, yeah.
I love that frame.
Thank you, thank you.
It's so stunning.
Thanks.
And the whole video is so beautiful.
Thank you.
Are you excited about this song?
It's so good,
but not to color it for you
Thank you.
but how do you feel about this song?
I think it's just super, super indicative of the time
I'm at in my life.
And I think a time that everyone has probably experienced.
I think the last two years of my life,
there was a lot thrown at me
that I was just expected to already know how to process,
be unfazed, keep it moving.
When it was things that were really making an impact on me
and changing me as a person.
So instead of kind of looking back on it
and being unforgiving to myself
and kind of beating myself down
for maybe mistakes I had made,
I was just like, "You know what?
This is just the time of my life,
where I am supposed to live.
I'm supposed to make mistakes."
And then we also just wanted
to turn it into a really fun dance song
and take some 60s vibes and make it something new.
Sabrina's latest single and music video,
Fast Times is out now.
Everybody's talking about it.
It's amazing and so are you.
Thank you.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪